and when you finish
okay welcome
um good evening and welcome to this
meeting of the planning committee
include including those watching online
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs either
through the security door to the right
of the chair here or opposite the lifts
in the foyer please do not use the lifts
please assemble in the Hawley Square on
the green officers will assist you and
advise when it's deemed safe to return
to the chamber does anyone intend to
film the meeting
I would advise that speakers using the
microphones are picked up by the cameras
recording this meeting and members of
the public in the public Gallery behind
the speakers may be picked up by those
cameras and have their images captured
any member of the public who objects to
the possibility of being filmed may wish
to take this opportunity to leave the
meeting
would everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber
whilst this meeting is in progress
I have the following members who wish to
speak under Council procedure rule 20.1
items four a and 4E counselor K bright
item 4 e councilor bambridge and cut
item 4f councilor Austin would any other
members who wish to speak under Council
procedure rule 20.1 please announce it
now
okay the following applications have
been reserved for public speaking item
4A 6 to 6A Luton Avenue broadstairs item
4E 45 to 45a York Street broadstairs
item 4f 22 Grosvenor Road broadstairs
and item 4G the Royal 51 Harbor Place
Ramsgate
I have apologies from councilor Dennis
and councilor ratigan who is substituted
by councilor Linda Wright
are there any other apologies
no are there any Declarations of
Interest
thank you
item three of the agenda do members
agree that the minutes of the planning
committee meeting held on the 19th of
July 2023 be approved as a correct
record do I have a proposal for that
please thank you councilor Keane and a
seconder
counselor mataphase
any site visits will take place for the
committee members on the morning of
Friday the 1st of September 2023.
so uh pop on to public speaking a gender
item for a this is an application for
approval
um
six to six a Luton Avenue speaking in
favor of this application is Mr Tony
Michael Mr Michael you have three
minutes
Madam chair members officers good
evening
this application has been informed by
the previous application and the appeal
which was dismissed and it took these
applications to inform this one before
you to identify all the issues which
have now all been addressed the officers
will explain these some will use the
dismissed appeal as a negative but in
fact it is a huge positive as it
identified all the issues which as we
say have been addressed
proof of this is for two years the
building has been in operation and there
has been no enforcement action no
investigations of any kind
it should not be called a HMO this is
the main problem HMO is a term that
people just do not like it is co-living
a New Concept it's not young people
being noisy causing problems late night
issues this is doctors nurses teachers
Civil Service immigration officers
customs and exercise some sleep during
the day as they work night shifts so it
is quiet the other tenants respect to
know this
when the case officer visited for her
site visit she noted how quiet it was
yes the report States the occupation
cannot be controlled by condition
correct but the applicant controls this
this is their business model for quality
but affordable housing there are four
kitchens four Living Spaces large
Gardens every room has an ensuite these
are facts you may hear opinion and
perception from others tonight like one
neighbor who stated wait till it starts
to operate it will be a nightmare it has
been operating for two years they didn't
realize this so it is not a nightmare no
harm caused in these two years of
operation fact you may be told of a
traffic survey produced by a neighbor
but this is a hatchet job with all due
respect it hasn't been seen or
scrutinized by the Kent highways
director who scrutinized our several
reports before they would accept and
approve them we have the facts and
professional reports six traffic reports
in total at different times one sound
assessment Kent highways director no
objection Environmental Services agree
with the sound assessment and say it is
competently produced senior planning
officer agrees and recommends approval
signed off and approved by the principal
and chief planning officers it has a HMO
license by your licensing department all
facts this application has had a
multi-tiered level of professional
scrutiny by the professional Departments
of the council and Kent County Council
fact not just I don't want it here
because it's a HMO it is not a HMO It Is
co-living by sensible mature persons to
refuse the application before use to say
to doctors teachers nurses essential
workers who are on work contracts and
not permanently employed so they cannot
obtain mortgages for houses or even rent
Flats is to say to them we don't want
you here and we won't support quality
and affordable housing for you I'm sure
this is not the message this Council
wants to project thank you
thank you speaking against the
application is Mr Richie Wilkinson Mr
Wilkinson you have three minutes
thank you madam chair Council
in April the planning inspector
dismissed an application for a 17 Bad
HMO on this site on the grounds of one
the unacceptable effects of living
conditions and neighboring residents two
the character and appearance of the area
three reduced Greenery four significant
increase in movement noise and
disturbance from the house of garden and
five the rear car park and access
adjacent to number eight the planning
inspector states that each of the above
reasons is on its own sufficient to
dismiss the appeal and concludes that
the harm caused by the scheme
significantly and demonstrably outweighs
any benefits arising from the provision
of the HMO
only the last of these issues has been
addressed where does the proposal
demonstrate respect enhancement and
conservation of the character of the
area where are the provisions for
disabled users the requirements of ho19
qd02 qd03 bsp-9 are still not satisfied
no consideration has been given to the
impact of disturbance on neighbors over
the last two years there have been late
night parties overflowing waste bins
wheelchair users impeded by cars parked
on the pavement I have had to move my
children into another bedroom because of
shouting and foul language from the
property what more compelling evidence
is needed to show the detrimental
effects on this neighborhood ho19 is a
safeguarding policy not a Target this
building is currently the largest HMO in
broadstairs this in itself represents a
concentration of use approval will
likely lead to a proliferation of
similar applications
the applicant's case relies heavily on
the traffic report submitted with the
application we commissioned a
professional engineer to review this
report they have questioned the
assumptions and conclude that the
applicant has significantly
underestimated vehicle movement claimed
for the HMO we've also submitted
evidence to show the care home occupancy
has been exaggerated by the report it
can be demonstrated that the HMO
generates more traffic movement than the
care home there is no discussion of this
in the officer's report
the inspector is clear that the harm
should not outweigh the benefit of such
a scheme so where is the benefit
condition 2 proposes that 16 persons
should occupy the property as principal
or main residence but the client group
currently in the residence are largely
contract shift workers whose main
addresses are elsewhere the scheme is
therefore not providing respite to a
local housing need
broadstairs neighborhood plan is clear
that appropriate action to bring the
building back into use appendix 5
supports the conversions of existing
houses in multiple occupation into
self-contained floods thus mitigating
the risks associated with hmos to Grant
permission for the HMO in these
circumstances is a complete repudiation
of the policies mandated by referendum
and undermines local democracy
thank you
thank you speaking under Council rule
20.1 is councilor Christian bright
thank you chair
I called this in owing to the weight of
objections from local residents with
over over 66 separate letters posted on
the planning portal let's be clear this
is not this is an HMO uh and it's being
like and it being licensed as licensed
as such should not be seen as material
evidence in support of the planning
application there are valid concerns
around the appearance of this
development but I'm going to use my
three minutes to focus on the impact to
neighboring properties the local plan
states that HMO proposals will be
permitted whether development does not
give rise to an unacceptable impact on
the living conditions of neighboring
residents through noise of General
disturbance
likewise the broadstairs and St Peter's
neighborhood plan states that
consideration will be given to the
effect of noise disturbance increased
parking demand and the like on the local
environment
firstly traffic and parking local
residents commission their own traffic
report as Mr as Richard just said uh in
the bay and correct errors in the base
assumptions made by the developers
report this survey outlines an increase
in traffic and parking due to fewer
Journeys generated by the previous
Assisting Living Home that housed
between 9 and 11 elderly residents and
more Journeys 44 compared to 17
generated by the proposed development
being more akin to private Flats than
local Authority housing as this property
already operates as an HMO we already
know the impact that this change of use
has on neighbors living conditions they
can't sleep HMO residents are shift
workers and are coming and going
throughout the night and early hours
this means Associated traffic and
conversations between residents and
completely negates the soundscape survey
provided by the developer as there is no
background noise at 2 am
the football also the football also
triggers overly bright security lighting
which shines directly into neighboring
houses
neighbors haven't been able to enjoy
their Gardens due to loud music and
anti-social Behavior by the residents of
this HMO complaints were made directly
to the developer about this
workers for the developer also destroyed
the mature hedge which formed the
boundary to number eight and whose
ownership at the time was still being
disputed these factors have been so
disruptive that Neighbors at number
eight have had to move their children's
bedrooms as they couldn't sleep through
the disturbances
this alone represents the very
definition of unacceptable impact and is
totally at odds with the inspector's
contention that there is no significant
change in living amenity for neighboring
property occupiers this application
remains contrary to both the thanet
local and broadstairs and Peter's
neighborhood plans it's scale nature and
design is just not in keeping with the
area and by removing just a single room
for the from the previous failed
applications this developer is showing
scant regard for Neighbors concerns I
strongly recommend that this committee
refuses permission in this case
thank you the planning applications
manager will now outline the report
thank you chair
so this is a aerial view of the uh of
Luton Avenue and surrounding roads so
the application proposes the change of
use of number six and six a just to be
clear the properties are actually
attached physically attached to the this
is the the gis map which hasn't been
updated but the building as you'll see
is is
attached to they're attached to each
other and it's to change it to a 16 bed
HMO so you've already heard about a
number of the issues that have come up
from the planning history of this case
specifically the main issue for members
to consider is policy ho19 of the local
plan and that states that the council
should permit housing multiple
occupation where and I'll just read out
the criteria so it wouldn't give rise in
terms of the impact on living conditions
of neighboring residents through noise
or general disturbance that it wouldn't
result in intensification or
concentration of such uses detrimental
to the immunity and character of the
neighborhood
that it provides suitable car parking or
adequate on-street parking is available
within the vicinity of the site and it
provides suitable bin storage
so we've already had mention of the
previous application that was refused
for a 17 bed HMO I think it's worth
reading out these reasons for refusal
for relevance so the the first reason
that the previous application was
refused for was that the proposed change
of use by virtue of the increased demand
for parking number of residents and
restricted parking area would would
result in additional parking pressure on
the area where there is reduced on
street parking provision uh
significantly harmful to park immunity
in the area and contrary to the relevant
policies and that the proposed use by
virtue of the location and proximity of
the parking area and the side entrance
door to the boundary of number eight
Luton Avenue would result in a
significant increase in noise
disturbance the neighboring residential
property causing significant harm as a
living immunity now members will have
seen because it's Annex one in the
report the inspector's decision
subsequently so this is relevant because
it dismissed and detailed some concerns
in a bit more detail so it talked about
movement to and from the premises and
that would result in noise and
disturbance from the house and Garden in
a in a quiet residential areas defined
it specifically looked at the impact on
number eight and identified the rear
parking area and the door but mainly the
parking area
to be an impact and then there were
other impacts on the appearance on the
streets in the character the area from
the parking area in itself and the
remove of the Landscaping that had
occurred
um the appeal decision does not talk
about on-street parking
um so just it is relevant that it
doesn't mention that obviously the
reason for refusal though has been
looked to be addressed
so just to go through some of the images
of the site so the Big Red Dot is on the
right hand side of the two properties
and then this is the current view of the
properties from this is actually from
November 2022 as you can see in the top
right hand corner so you've got the two
properties there you can see where there
is a route down the side of the property
on the left-hand side parking Air at the
front and then you can actually see the
side door which we'll talk about in a
minute here
and we've got another image from the
other side and then I've just got a
couple of images
of the front
and then this is looking down to number
eight is on your left as you look at it
and this is the rear parking area which
we'll come on to in a minute and then
this is on the right hand side looking
down the side alley
this is the rear of the premises so we
are um the left hand side at the back
but the right hand side at the front
looking back to the property and you can
see there's a fence that's been erected
on the right hand side
and this is here
and then this as it stands is the other
side of that fence in the parking area
that's being utilized at the moment with
the protected tree at the rear
so turning and sorry this is just a show
again a bit more detail that parking
area and then this is looking back
towards the side elevation of number
eight
and then this is the side door of the
property that we'll talk about
so
the main changes that have changed from
the previous application to this one is
the reduction from 17 to 16 people the
removal of this parking area so this is
proposed to be removed and landscaped
with a new gate and fence to be erected
next to the access door on the side it
also includes a change at the front to
be grasped to change from the sort of
slate shingle that's at the front at the
moment
it is proposed that the side door would
be
um designated as a fire door and will
show on the floor plans that that's
proposed to be restricted in terms of
entry and exit
and there's also obviously by virtue of
the removal of the on-site uh parking as
well you've also got to change to the
fence at the rear here to open up that
Garden area
so
in terms of the existing ground floor
plan as mentioned this site is in
operation I do think it's important just
to note the points have been raised
about the license process for licensing
HMO that is entirely separate from the
planning process and isn't shouldn't be
taken into account in terms of the
specific determinations that you have to
make under policy for a planning
application in addition in terms of any
enforcement action not being taken
you will note from the front page of the
appeal decision in terms of when the
decision was issued and then when the
appeal was actually issued there was a
very significant time period before the
appeal was actually issued and as
members will know we hold any
enforcement action into balance whilst
the planning appeal is going on because
obviously we don't want to take action
when an inspector can then obviously
approve something and then we are liable
for all the costs of taking that action
um
so you've currently got upstairs a total
number of rooms now in this rear area
here what's what's been proposed is that
it becomes one bedroom in in this area
but what I want to talk about now is
this is the ground floor plan so in
terms of the side door this is
identified obviously in the previous
decision by the council as an issue and
what's being proposed is that there
would be a control on that use of that
door that it would only open in the
activation of the fire alarm by an
electromagnetic door release now I don't
believe that that is currently in situ
however irrespective of whether or not
it is or isn't there is a proposed
planning condition which is condition
nine which would require uh if if this
was approved within a set time frame
details of the mechanism that would be
put into that far escape door to be
approved and then maintained
subsequently so that's a condition that
we would propose to go on the
application if it were to be approved
in terms of the impact on noise to
residents
the applicator has submitted a noise
assessment
um and obviously you've heard some of
the the views with regards to that noise
assessment
um I do think it's important to draw
members attention to the comments of the
environmental health officer who has
looked at the noise assessment and does
consider it to be sound in what it is
assessing which does show that the
background noise level
when those studies were taken was
predominantly created by the noise from
the road
obviously it is inevitable that some
noise is not going to be captured by a
noise assessment what the main change
though that has occurred from one
proposal to another here is the removal
of the rear parking area which means
that no cars would be going down the
side axis of number eight so that does
reduce the amount of noise clearly which
will be exacerbated and has been clearly
occurring with regards to the Park area
at the rear being used at different
times of day that would be removed in
addition and the restriction on the use
of that Side Access
um you know from now onwards if
permission were to be granted would look
to remove then that being used as a
frequent method of access and you can
see on this plan there is a main access
in the middle of the property which
would then be used by the 16 occupants
so the environmental health officer has
concluded that it's not considered that
the comings and goings from the site
would make a significant difference to
the background noise level on the basis
of the evidence that's been submitted
now
this is just the first floor plan and
shows the bedroom at the back as I
mentioned that's now a single single
bedroom
so in terms of traffic
you've heard that there's a submission
of information that's been done to do
with the amount of movements that were
created by the previous use of the
building and then the new use the
building and as you'll see from the
officer report it acknowledges that
there is and there would be an increase
in on-street parking from the proposed
use that is our that was our stance
previously and it's still our stance now
what we didn't have with the previous
application is the evidence that has
been submitted by the applicant and has
been assessed by KCC highways so on the
image on your left is looking at the
areas which were looked at specifically
by the survey it was that was done so
the roads in red were looked at in terms
of what parking
um is present on street and the image on
the right
looks at where there are restrictions on
the ability to park on the street so you
won't be able to sit in a lot of detail
but every single line on that road or
where there is a a measurement is where
there is a dropped curb and there are
single yellow lines or indeed there's a
long blue line that goes along the veil
which is basically saying you cannot
park here because anyone that's driven
along the vale will know you can't park
on both sides that road is too narrow
um what that parking survey demonstrated
um was initially the parking survey was
done on a Wednesday and Thursday 26th
and 27th of April KCC put in an initial
objection to the survey work that had
been done and actually asked for the
reinstatement of parking at the rear and
but further Evidence was provided with a
Saturday service out of the 8th of July
which was put in with a midday survey
and a an evening sorry um a 2 pm survey
and then a midnight survey
um and this identified as the previous
surveys did that there were spaces in
the vicinity both at night time and
daytime and the figures are within the
report now KCC have looked through that
and they've considered this in the round
given that the site is in a sustainable
location it's 10 minutes walk away from
the station it's close to a bus route
and it was not considered given the
evidence that's been submitted that
there would be a significantly detriment
and mental impact on highway safety by
virtue of the amount of parking that
would be created by the use and that
that would be able to be accommodated
within the streets surrounding in terms
of the query about the number of
movements created by the use
um the main issue created by the use is
actually the parking rather necessarily
than the movements if the movements if
there was still a rear parking area the
number of movements is absolutely an
issue because then you're looking at the
number of movements adjacent to the
neighbors in this instance it's about
actually how much parking is available
in the area and whether or not that can
accommodate the 16 residents if they all
had a car can they Park in the area and
the view of KCC highways and indeed
backed up by offices is is that in from
our in our view that is possible to
happen without causing any highway
safety concerns specifically due to the
number obviously concern has been raised
about how people Park
that unfortunately isn't something that
can be taken into account it's it's
that's an individual that could happen
irrespective of the accommodation
um it's about whether or not the
situation itself creates a problem in
particular streets because there are too
much on street parking and that's not
borne out by the evidence that we have
in front of us
now
this is a this is a tricky Case by
virtue of
I'll just skip through these photos if
we need to come back to those we can
this is a tricky case because you've
seen obviously there are significant
concerns about the the use of the
building that have been addressed
um
there have been changes made to the
proposal it is very clearly dealing with
some of the issues that were raised
previously and we do consider as
officers that the additional evidence
that's been submitted does demonstrate
that it overcomes the issues raised by
the previous refusal it does deal with a
number of the issues deal with that
raised by the inspector and a
combination of the removal of the
parking area the restriction on the fire
escape and the additional evidence
that's been produced with regards to the
noise report that it does overcome the
reasons raised by the inspector as well
now on balance therefore it is
recommended for approval that is subject
to a number of safeguarding conditions
which does include reinstatement or
in-statement of the Landscaping in terms
of the fence there's a restriction on
the occupancy to 60 individuals and
obviously the restrictions on the actual
fire escape door on the side and so we
do think it comply is with policy h019
and bsp-9 of the neighbor plan thank you
thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted can Vice chair
please second that seconded
sorry
I pressed it and it was off
um so now open for debate
um councilor bayford
is
a very very difficult
um
application to decide upon
the fact that
the building has been the building so
councilor bayford could you just move
your microphone down towards you a
little bit bend it a little bit is that
okay is that better thank you thank you
sorry the fact yeah I think it's a very
difficult one to decide um the fact that
the buildings have been operating for
two years with few issues to the point
where many residents didn't even know
that it was acting as an HMO
um I I think it's quite important
um I think hmos are essential in
providing affordable affordable housing
for people who need it including
professionals who we do need to attract
to the area
um I can can't see why the traffic
movement would increase
um and in fact the uh environmental
officer has
sort of Health office says that the
noise level is from the road
um changes have been made to address the
issues raised I'm unsure but I generally
feel that I'm in support of this
application thank you
thank you Council Auburn
yes thank you chair I I I agree with the
councilor bayford in the in that is a
difficult
one to determine
um
if this was a six bed most hmos within
sanit are are less
than 10 probably six on average you know
the house converted into six
fair enough and we do need those type of
we do need that kind of availability
um
co-living no HMO yes
um I I I I do take into account what um
what the agent for the applicant was
saying about doctors nurses and other
professionals
however
I do know that doctors nurses and other
professionals uh do like to get uh do
get carried away and do they're like
every other person on this planet and
they're not all Meek and quiet and
whatever so you know that's that's just
a for one of a better phrase that's uh a
red herring
um
also
we're talking 16 single people come on
not going to be 16 single people is it
don't they ever life these people don't
they have Partners or don't they go no
it's going to be more than that you
could double that
um you could double that so you could be
looking at 32 people living here it's
too many people in one location for it
to be quiet I'm sorry but that is the
case you know that's just that's that's
just being human you know if you're a
lot of people in one place then it's
going to be it's not going to be a quiet
place is it
um I have to say the building looks very
well kept it looks in good condition
um
and if it had come in for uh if you're
coming for self-contained Fletch then I
think that would be far far better than
this use
um however
um
I wish to hear what other members have
to say thank you chair
it's a Livingstone for a moment
um
thank you chair um yeah to your point
councilman I I agree that there's
nothing that precludes guests visiting
people that live there that that is true
um in terms of the condition it's it's
requiring that no more than 16 person
should occupy the property as the
principal or main residence any one time
but to your point yes that doesn't
preclude people staying there is not
their principal resident
oh that's her album come back yeah
I understand that however
human nature uh
who's going to is that a condition on
the planning consent or there should
only be 16 people in Residence
but yes it's conditioned two okay who's
going to enforce that
that would be us as the local planning
Authority
you're not going to visit here uh on a
very on a very regular basis are you
um so I I don't I mean I'm I'm
definitely not going to talk about
planning enforcement with Council Auburn
particularly on this but I would say
that obviously if there was a breach or
a a rate you know a concern was raised
that this was being breached then
obviously there are lots of tools that
we would have such as a planning
contravention notice which should
obviously require information
requisition information but as you say
it is a it's a priority service so it
you know it would just it's a it's it's
I think it's an enforceable condition
that's what I'd say
thank you
councilor Mata face thank you chair um
when this was an Abbey field assisted
living there were I think 10 or 11
individual little Flats so I think that
is an enormous difference going from a
dozen or so elderly or disabled people
who tended to be less mobile I think
going from that number to 16 quite
honestly is a step too far and
um they would I mean I know there was a
traffic survey and there were some
movements yes there would have been
visitors there would have been carers
coming in but that is a vast difference
between 16 people driving driving to and
from work and I'm going to find it
difficult to support this I know this
area well and parking there at any point
particularly when the schools are
operating Ace College oh sorry
broadstairs college now is operating
that area is heavily parked up because
it has been said a lot of the properties
have dropped curbed I think it's gonna
be very difficult for these people to
find summer on the street to park and I
think that is taking it it's a step too
far
thank you councilor Keane
thank you and I'm concerned about the
quality of it because of the number of
of flat lips whatever one calls them in
there I mean you know I'm looking at the
um on the left hand side the top bedroom
well the door from the shower area
practically hits the diagram of the bed
I mean it doesn't seem a very spacious
area at all I presume there are minimum
standards and I presume it meets them
but that's my concern you know is it
really providing quality accommodation
for people
thank you sir so in the in policy qdo4
which is the technical standards under
the the nationally described space
standards that doesn't cover hmos what
we've previously looked at with hmos is
whether or not
um you have
communal areas you have kitchens and
obviously you have appropriate bathroom
facilities often that does though relate
to much smaller hmos and those sorts of
proposals have been in front of members
before when there's a question over you
know is it except we have three beds or
four bed property depending on if
there's a lounge Etc
so we consider that even though
obviously you point out that the one on
the left and at the top
um the individual rooms are all quite
spacious for individual rooms but also
there is there are communal areas and
you can see there are two lounge areas
that are present on this floor Alone
um there is as I mentioned the separate
requirement very much separate the HMO
licensing requirement which Moore looks
at you know a number of kitchens per
bedroom and number of bathrooms per
bedroom that sort of thing but in terms
of the standard of accommodation we do
consider this to be acceptable when
looking at it and you know comparing it
really to Flat conversion standards in
terms of how big bedrooms are it's it's
it's sufficient
councilor wing
Council again go first Council of Garner
all right thank you yeah I've listened
with interest to what people have said
about this and to what this
agent and the resident that said and I
think
because this is a similar application
has been considered and refused
previously and gone to appeal and the
refusal upheld by the inspector I'm sort
of guided
um by the inspector's report on this to
in my thinking and as has been mentioned
the inspector
came up with three different reasons why
the
um refusal was upheld
and then said as was mentioned each of
these reasons
on its own is sufficient to dismiss the
appeal so to my mind that means that
each of those three reasons has to be
satisfied to enable this to be approved
now the the second about the parking we
can we can agree or disagree on whether
the new arrangements to move parking
completely off-site onto on to vote onto
the road
continues to be unably as the inspector
said the partial parking was is
something that can be argued
and significantly reducing the amount of
greenery in the back Garden
that is Again by taking away the car
park and you are
potentially satisfying that reason for
refusal the main reason that I really am
struggling with and I can't see
we get round is that
by having 17 residents occupying these
houses the noise generated by a care
home would be normally expected to be
Visa is due the introduction of 17
individual into
individuals into an HMO in a quiet
street we likely to generate significant
movement to and find the promises as
well as noise and disturbance so the way
that this
reason is being satisfied is by reducing
that number for 17 to 16 and
to argue that that fully satisfies
that that will no longer be
generating unacceptable noise I find
extremely difficult to agree with and
unless someone
here can satisfy me that that is the
case then I'm going to struggle to agree
to approve this application thank you
okay cancel the wing uh like counselor
Alvin has said normally you get a single
dwelling with with five or six maybe
four four four four four units
uh here we've got two units two
properties side by side which just
further impacts on the neighbors uh 16
beds 32 people could be
visitors with also with cars that are
parking on the street uh I just think
it's it's over development it would have
been it would have been nice to have
seen them as units flat units that we
desperately need as well
uh I just find it quite difficult that
the noise assessment wasn't undertaken
during the night when we all know the
slightest drop of a pin or a
conversation on the street actually is
is very loud if you're indoors certainly
happens on my street quite a lot uh
and we haven't got HMO but I don't know
I find it difficult if there'd have been
one property it would have been better
it just seems there's so much of it
there all in one place on a street
that's not used to this number of adults
living in one property active adults
active working adults that are to and
from and busy and do what adults do
so I'm going to struggle as well I'm
afraid
thank you councilor ezeki
yeah mine's a question actually Brian
um they stated that this has been
operating for two years have you
actually had any complaints noise
complaints come through the council that
you know of
I'm afraid I can't speak to that with
regards to Environmental Health in case
they had um received anything as a sort
of statutory nuisance complaint
obviously this is a slightly unique case
because of the fact that the previous
proposal was at appeal so obviously any
sort of complaints with regards to
enforcement about any impact would be
effectively the response would be you
know we have to hold action events until
the appeal is determined so it's it's
difficult to say in terms of whether or
not we've got any recorded complaints
into that effect
to address the issue of the spaciousness
of the of the accommodation
people need affordable accommodation
they need some people need to have to
professional people in particular need
to have a place to live that does that
they can afford we cannot always have
spacious accommodation I think sometimes
we look to build too many places that
are unaffordable so for that is another
reason why I think perhaps hmos are very
very important thank you
foreign
just coming in on one point raised
earlier the the noise information did
look at background noise level in terms
of at night time
um just so that that's clear however I
do think it's important that this was
taken at a specific time in I think it's
May this year so I think given the way
that this property has been occupied and
obviously which happens with every HMO
in terms of it can vary depending on who
the individuals are I think that's where
there might be some disparity into how
much noise is created by different
movements at different times of day but
I just wanted to make that clear in
terms of the evidence that's been put
forward that's been looked at about
environmental health was on that basis
thank you
do I have any other speakers
councilor bright
yeah thank you chair um just a question
really so how can we guarantee that the
um fire door will definitely only be
used
um in uh as an exit in the event of an
emergency and also
um I was actually quite shocked at the
sort of
the um the way the way the Landscaping
has been managed to be honest the fact
that I mean I saw before and after
pictures and that used to be a very
beautiful front garden with a hedge and
it just looks quite brutal to be honest
um how can we guarantee as well that
that's going to be a beautifully
landscaped Garden
um as it was before
um at the moment it's it's just hardcore
and I know that qdo2 says something
about design and I certainly don't think
they enhances the character of the area
in its current state
thank you
thank you yes so the first point with
regards to the the fire escape door so
condition nine
um identifies that it's got to be the
door's got to be fitted with the
mechanism that only allows opening the
event of activation of the fire alarm
and with details submitted for the local
Authority's approval
um within one month of a decision if it
were to be approved which would have to
also include a timetable for
installation and then it's got to be
fitted in accordance with the details
and maintaining good working order
and as we've included the statement to
be used only in the event of an
emergency fundamentally it's a deterrent
in terms of avoiding the fire alarm
going off if the fire alarm keeps going
off there may well be other statutory
nuisance issues that could be looked at
it is a deterrent in terms of its use
and obviously I'm sure that the
applicant would know that we are going
to get multiple complaints if it keeps
going off to the council by residents
and obviously we as the environment both
in terms of environmental health and
obviously planning would then be very
much looking at whether or not there's a
breach of the condition or indeed
there's a statue nuisance issue in terms
of the Landscaping
yeah you know absolutely agree the
current situation is is unacceptable
um what they are proposing to do however
was is to landscape both of those areas
which were which were created as they
were
um condition six requires details of
that landscape because we have the the
details that you can see there on the
plan in terms of grasp but we don't have
the tree species or the shrub species
and that would have to be submitted um
you know within three months of the
decision we then once that's been agreed
and then completed within photographic
evidence to be submitted as part of that
condition and we also require a
Landscape Management plan to be
submitted which is under condition eight
which would actually outline very
clearly about how they intend to
maintain that over a prolonged time
period from then on so again if that
doesn't happen it's a it's a breach of
condition and therefore it's a potential
breach condition notice
thank you
thank you councilman
yes thank you chair
firstly I'd like to fall in line with
councilor Garner on the inspectorates
um three points as we've just heard that
two of those points have been covered
but the last one being the numbers you
know only being reduced by one I
actually have the same concern and also
a question regarding the Hedge at the
front of the building was that dispute
of ownership ever resolved and if so is
it going to be replaced
I'm sorry I realized I've had my
microphone on um the
um I I don't know but it's it's
irrelevant in terms of the planning
determination I think is the main thing
it's a separate civil matter in terms of
the ownership so it couldn't be taken
into account with the decision
Council on that face I'd just like to
come back quoting from the inspector's
report
because much has been made about its
extra housing units he says the existing
care home also provides a holding
resource which I think was for about 11
and maybe 12 people and the harm caused
by the scheme significantly and
demonstrably outweighs and arising from
the provision of HMR so basically
looking as it was before as an Abbey
field with 11 or 12 and now 16 it's only
actually adding four or five more units
isn't it and working out the percentage
going from 17 to 16 is only a six
percent reduction it's a tiny reduction
by comparison so instead of having 12
elderly people living there you might
have 16 professional people which is
plus four
councilor Wing it's just clarification
over the the fire door does the fire
door when it's open Trigger the alarm or
does the alarm trigger the fire door
opening
well we'll be getting details of the
mechanism in however the expectation
would be you can't open the door unless
the fire alarm is triggered
no no you can't open the door unless the
fire alarm is activated so rather than
the idea if you push the door and the
fire alarm goes off because that would
be obviously problematic
okay do I have any other questions or
comments counselor more
yes Chad just to make a point that those
fire doors can be overpowered just by
pushing hard those magnetic locks are
not that secure and that's 30 years
experience
right and looks like I don't have any
more so we will now put the motion for
the officer's recommendation for
approval to the vote can I have those
who vote in favor please
and those against
thank you
any abstentions yeah do we have sorry
did I have any abstentions
no no abstentions
sorry the motion is lost
um what we now have to do is hand back
to Mr Livingstone because we will need
to uh produce another motion thank you
um okay so I've heard obviously the
issues that members have raised and
obviously as mentioned it was a balanced
case obviously taking account of the
information that's been submitted has
clearly been understood by members in
terms of the changes that were made to
the proposal
and in terms of the reason the previous
reasons for refusal and then the
subsequent inspector's decision and
taking all of that together I think
that's really important it's not just
about overcoming the planning uh sorry
the the council's decision but it's
about taking account of the inspection
decision as mentioned by councilor
Garner and then subsequently mentioned
by others about what's changed
um specifically the reason for refusal
that the council put forward related to
the impact on number eight with regards
to the door and the parking area however
as as read out parallel three of the
inspector's decision uh talks
specifically more more I suppose more
generally about the noise impact of
having at that point 17 and people and
it's not I think important thing here is
it's
not just necessarily more just more
movement to and from the premises but
where it states as well as noise and
disturbance from the house and Garden
in terms of the other elements of the
refuse or previously
um I think certainly in in officer's
view there is there is considered to be
sufficient capacity in the area to
accommodate for this in terms of parking
and again the site is a sustainable
location in terms of ability of people
to walk um to the station
I think therefore the main issue that
members have raised really is about the
increased activity from the users of the
HMO because there are 16 users the HMO
even given the changes that have been
made and so I don't know whether or not
if the chair agrees it might be worth a
brief adjournment for anyone that wants
to come up here to discuss a potential
motion to put forward to members
agree with a brief adjournment would
anyone who wants to input to the revised
motion please come forward thank you
um just we have got a revised motion to
bring before members but we have a
missing member so um we're just waiting
for um councilor makinson to return to
the chamber so oh and I'm here she is
thank you
okay now now we now we have a full
compliment again um I will hand over to
uh Mr Livingstone again thank you
uh thank you chair so um discussion
focused around the issues that members
have raised and specific reference to
the inspector's decision uh taking
account of the previous
um Council decision
um and it's considered that at the
following motion um be put before
members to refuse the application on the
following ground that the proposed
change of use by virtue of the increased
activity from the users of the HMO would
result in a detrimental increase in
noise and disturbance to neighboring
Residential Properties causing uh sorry
causing harm to the living conditions of
the occupiers and character of the area
contrary to policies h019 and qd03 of
the planet local plan policy bsp nine of
the broadstairs in Saint Peter's
neighborhood plan paragraph 130 of the
national planning policy framework
um can I have a proposal please
counselor Alban secondary
Council of Garner thank you
um
and can I have votes in favor of that
please
and those against
thank you that's Carriage were there any
abstentions
sorry with two abstentions that's
carried
okay that's the end of that item um I
know that I realize there are quite a
few people
um in the gallery who were here for that
item you can stay or you can leave um
it's entirely up to you
um so if you want to carry on listening
to what follows that's fine but you
don't have to
I'll just I'll just pause a minute while
we have a mass Exodus
okay
okay thank you
um so a gender item four
um 45 to 45 a York Street song
sorry 4A I've just been corrected item
four e
um 45 to 45 a York Street speaking in
favor of the application is Mr Tony
Michael three minutes
uh Madam chair I'm not actually speaking
in favor of it uh councilor bambridge's
fair enough
um in that case councilor Banbridge
thank you chair
so I'm here to talk on the little
Sicilian
um you're going to be asked to judge
whether the existing flu belonging to
the little Sicilian restaurant in
broadstairs is disruptive obtrusive and
out of keeping with the street scene I
hope that you had a chance to look at
the photos that I sent you earlier to
see this isn't actually the case and
that the flu is hardly noticeable at all
the report states that environmental
health have no objections as they've
accepted the specifications the flu are
compliant with odor and noise control
bull says Town Council have no objection
nor does the broadstairs society this
must indicate to you that the flu is
absolutely fine and does not in any way
harm the conservation area the flu
installation was an honest mix-up the
Italian owners of the restaurant was
somewhat misled by the flu company and
did not realize that the larger flu was
being installed however this flu is fine
and has been in place one and one and a
half years and there were no additional
complaints from the public domain since
the initial complaint from the labor
this objection is just on the appearance
as per the report the report states that
the extraction system by virtue of its
size and prominent sighting is an unduly
disruptive obtrusive and incongruous
feature unrelated to and out of keeping
with the established Street Scene to the
detriment of the character and visual
amenities of the conservation area and
detrimental to the visual communities
enjoyed by the occupiers of adjoining
properties the flu is none of these
things and just to remind you there's
always been a flu to this building
there's always been a cafe or restaurant
here the report says that the bamboo
screen used to ameliate the ameliorate
this is not acceptable as it's not
permanent and it has and it has to be
maintained well this bamboo screening is
a is a principle that's been accepted in
many other cases to screen buildings for
example the Harbor View next to the Tata
frigar bamboo is accepted to screen the
entire building and they now say it's
not acceptable to screen a small flu
so where is the consistency here the flu
cannot be seen and there is and it is no
way disruptive or prominent it is set
back from the side street and this
business doesn't need the cost of
extracting
um and this the existing flu and
installing a smaller flu when the flu is
actually fine as it is also the
suggestion to paint it black as the
report States wouldn't be a good idea as
this would make it more visible as a
silver flu it Blends in with the
backgrounds and sky so it's hardly
noticeable you can see for yourself if
you wish to make a site with it but
honestly I don't really think a site
visit is necessary if you've been able
to look at the pictures and I hope you
recognize that there really isn't a
problem here the little Sicilian is a
hard-working small business that
deserves our support in hard times so a
lot of hospitality businesses are
closing their doors we don't want to put
this business under any more unnecessary
pressure that said I hope you as a
committee are in agreement with me and
we'll go against the office officer's
recommendation to refuse permission
thank you
thank you speaking under Council rule
20.1 is councilor Christian bright three
minutes
thank you chair um I'll I'll be brief on
this
um I wanted to speak on this as it was
something I did pick up during the local
campaign uh the local election
campaigning
um and it was specifically talking about
the uh the flu itself with the the next
door neighbor who
um told me at the time that her
enjoyment of the property of their
property has been negatively impacted by
the the presence of the flu both in
terms of the view and the visual
immunity and the uh the the odors um
within her house
um I agree with the recommendation of
refusal of refusal on the grounds that
due to its size this flu is detrimental
to the visual immunity of the
broadstairs Conservation Area
um the attempts to hide the flu while
loadable are inappropriate and
inadequate with no permanent fixture or
planting plan I think the applicant
needs to think again about this and
recommend the committee supports the
officer's recommendation and refuses the
application
that's all
thank you the principal planning officer
will now outline the report
yes thank you chair
so this is the application site which it
outlined in red here at the corner of
York Street and Oscar Road
um again this is enough of you of the
application site and the area we're
talking about is the area hatched in
blue here so it fronts onto Oscar Road
so this is again an aerial photograph
and this is the application site here
and the area we're talking about is in
this location here
um as has been mentioned this is a site
in the broadstairs conservation area so
it is
um expected to in either enhance or at
least maintain the character and
appearance and the special features of
that Conservation Area
and as you can see this is the
application site here and as you'll note
it's the surrounding areas a variety of
residential and Commercial premises
and the application before members
tonight is part retrospective and it's
for the erection of the extraction
system and flow with freestanding bamboo
screening which has been mentioned by
speakers already to the north so in the
Northern and Eastern and ages of the
roof extension and a regularization of
the existing handrail
so we'll just look at some photographs
of the site
um these are
um I think some photographs newer
photographs have been circulated to
members which now include
um screening along the frontage of the
site here but these were taken a little
while ago but you can see the screening
the bamboo screening to the side here so
this extension was granted
um in 2022
and it was meant to have an internal flu
and that's what's been mentioned by
councilor Banbridge about the mix-up and
it was put on and and we are looking as
being partly retrospective but it is to
maintain the flu
so that's enough of you of it
and again a close-up view of this flu
here and as you can see it is silver and
appearance metallic
it doesn't in office's opinion blend
with the sort of subservient nature of
the wooden extension or the surrounding
sort of more traditional buildings in
the area
and just to give you an idea of
measurements of that flu it is 0.5
meters in diameter
and has a length of a total length of
9.96 meters of which 600 sorry 6.35
meters runs along the boundary of 43 B
York Street and 3.61 meters runs
opposite
along the extension line directly in
line
with the Oscar Road number three
so again enough of you of it and you can
see the bamboo screening here but the
members just to point out there is some
gaps in screening and it is not
officers are concerned that that
screening may not be sufficient to
totally cover
the flu and this is very well managed
and that's just enough of you again
where you can see the screening
isn't you know totally covering it as
yet albeit that we are aware it is only
been recently sort of put in
and that's enough of you that's actually
taken from street view
and
so that's it
sorry yeah
oh sorry yes sorry this is a photo that
was taken before any screening was in
place so you can see it hasn't got it
but you can see it is quite noticeable
in its silver color and set it in
office's opinion and we do raise
concerns about the impact on the
character and appearance of the
Conservation Area
so just looking at some elevations this
is the elevation as existing it's
slightly wrong in that it should the flu
isn't in existence
but and
so apologies if I'm not talking
correctly into the microphone as I say
this is an existing front elevation
that's been provided by the agent as I
say it's slightly misleading because the
flu obviously is in existence and was
before the application was put in but if
we go to the front proposed front
elevation this is showing it with the
screening in place to the front so it is
showing in this instance that it would
be covered by the screening and you
would not see it from standing in Oscar
Road you also note from the annotations
and the report that the proposal is to
paint the flu and the extraction pipes
and ducting black
so in an attempt to further blend it in
so have more um in common with the
building it sits on
so this is the existing side Innovation
again slightly
um odd without showing the flu that is
in existence but this is where we've
looked at photographs
this is showing the bamboo planting
there this is the rear elevation and
this is the proposed rear elevation
um so just a quick look at some floor
plans this was before the extension was
in place actually so it was used as for
bin storage and other things associated
with the restaurant this is the
extension here in that yard where we saw
the bins and the bin storages now in
location here
and this is the existing first floor
plan
so it had some tables
an office etc for the management
and again this is the same first floor
plan but you can see the
the extension down here
so it really is for members to
as has been mentioned to decide whether
this
flew
can be adequately screened by bamboo
screening or and or painting it black
and whether it is detrimental to the
character appearance of the Conservation
Area
officers are of the opinion it does not
enhance or preserve the character and
appearance of the conservation area and
it is highly visible and whilst we have
sympathies with
um
the owners of the restaurants and
obviously their need to continue their
business there was an internal system
that was going to be put into the
extension originally so we whilst
environmental health do not raise an
objection officers do from a view point
of the character and appearance of the
area and that it is detrimental to the
special
and historic and Architectural
importance of the Conservation Area
are they
um
sorry a bit slightly unique I'm just
going to present my screen now because
we've we've got the photos in or which
are more up to date so I think it is
important for members to see those so if
you bear with me a second
um
so
um that is the image that's been
provided
um
which obviously shows the screening at
the front I do just want to confirm
something which I've just been looking
through the design next system and just
on this confusion about painting the
flow I'm going to do something that I
wouldn't normally suggest doing
and I'm actually going to look at Mr
Michael and just ask him to confirm or
not whether or not actually the proposal
was to paint the flow or not because
I've reread the design and access
statement and it's to paint the railings
the spiral staircase on the left of this
image and the railing back but I don't
think it includes painting the flu in
the design and access statement
I think on the drawing it states that we
would paint the flue and of course we
would paint the flue if this is what the
officers required
so I think it's on the drawings
I'm sorry it says there's a there's a
gap on the drawing and so I just wanted
to just ascertain that definitely for
members so everyone was absolutely clear
on what was being considered thank you
for that I appreciate it
um so yeah just to show members this
image but again um this is obviously
what's what's being proposed in front of
members in terms of the screening and
their officer recommendation is for
refusal
okay I'm just checking what's going on
there
um right in that case um I moved the
officer's recommendation is adopted
um could Vice chair please second
indeed thank you
um and uh could I've got lots of hands
up going up so I saw councilor Mata face
first
uh sorry I I've got a whole lot so um
I'm going to start with counselor Mata
face thank you chair
um this is a horizontal flu am I I've
got I've got two or three questions one
is is the only reason why there can't be
an external vertical flu in the back of
the property uh second question you
mentioned an internal system would that
be a fallback position if
um this refuse will go through and
this is discharging straight into the
street at a height of what what seven or
eight feet which is not very pleasant
for the people in Oscar Road and my last
point I want to make is bamboo requires
quite a lot of depth and looks to me
like those Planters are quite shallow so
I have no idea how long that bamboo
would survive up there particularly in
our current rather dry climate so why
not vertical is there a fallback
position
discharging to the streets can't be very
very pleasant and also I don't think the
bamboo plant has the right depth
right I saw councilor bayford
thank you Chet yeah I mean I think that
the the pictures show now are very
different to those that we saw
previously
this is a thriving business and
I think that every every
move possible has been made to comply it
with the requirements of the
Conservation Area
I think it's very harsh to refuse this
thank you
councilor wing
I'm a bit confused because the original
planning application for the extension
had the flu inside the building
so how do you go for how do you forget
to put the flu inside the building and
then you end up with this thing on the
top of the building that quite frankly
if it was in Margate it'd be a really
good piece of artwork for everybody to
look at but I'm quite confused that you
can obviously add my own building
recently that you can forget something
as significant as a flu that large you
can forget to put it inside the building
we had a similar thing but not a similar
thing on Charlotte Court in Ramsgate
where the where the the company just
decided to smash through the wall and
put a flu in in the in Charlotte Court
which was a primary a prime location
they should have just followed and done
what they did in their original planning
application and I'm sure we wouldn't be
here wasting time
councilman no was there anyone else
councilor Auburn
yeah thank you chair
um
again about whether it should be inside
or outside
um
if it was to be inside and just remind
me if I got it wrong but I I believe
that the company put it in or were doing
the flu put it on the outside instead of
on the inside I think if if that was if
that's remember if that was my memories
right
um so the issue really if that is the
case is between the owner and the people
who put the the extracts are up
um instead of just accepting it if I was
the owner of that I want them to put it
where it should be in the first place
not where they decided it was if it was
going to go
um so
I wasn't sure if uh it was councilor
bambridge who actually said that or not
but anyway thank you
okay councilman
did you
no okay I'm I'm getting dust tears over
here councilor King
I just wanted to say this is the
conservation area and I mean what does
it mean if we let something like this
stay in the area
now councilman
yes thank you chair chair work this is
not the first time this has happened in
broadstairs with the extraction systems
um and there have been a retrospection
applications for this uh likewise and
they have by the size of it
um it's difficult to reduce it in size I
think but they have been screened more
adequately and made to blend in with its
surroundings it's unfortunate that it's
not internal as it was originally I
think it would be quite harsh to
um
to change that because that would affect
the business in its in its um its
Channel running but I think if the
bamboo was removed in adequate screening
was put in to make it blend in so you
wouldn't see it
um like false cladding as you've got on
the side in the front of the building
there just to raise it slightly so it's
hidden that would go in part to make it
blend in and you wouldn't have to paint
it I think the bamboos takes time to
grow and therefore it's
I don't know why they've done that maybe
the ecology side the green side but I
think it's harsh to refuse it but I
think the adequate cladding should be
made to obscure it thank you
thank you I don't have anyone else
um who wanted a comment so I'm going to
take a moment of a chair's privilege to
make my own comment I am very concerned
at the maintenance of bamboo on the roof
I'm also quite concerned that the
appearance which actually just looks
like it
could be weeds growing up there I
appreciate it's uh probably bamboo so
it's to agree with actually councilor
Moore and the concerns raised by Council
no matter face I think there should be
some alternative type of screening then
what is there
I'm sorry
I'm sorry there is no uh comment um
available from the
um from
no
okay um oh councilor wing
I just want to try and reiterate they
put a planning application in to build
an extent extension with an internal
flow and they haven't done that
so by approving by going against the
officer's wishes are we undermining the
planning process
okay anyone else
um no okay in that case we need to uh
put the motion for the officer's
recommendation for refusal to the vote
those in favor of the officer's
recommendation
and those against
any obsessions
thank you
so the officer's recommendation is
carried for refusal
nine in favor three against and one up
step one abstention thank you
so the next item on the agenda is item
four F 22 Grosvenor Road
speaking in favor of the application I
have Mr Beaumont
three minutes
thank you madam chairman um I'm Mike
Bowen the owner of the four candles
microbrewery in St Peters I've been
granted permission for a modest
extension to our cold store building in
Grosvenor Road
my application is only for a pitched
roof to the building to replace the
sloping corrugated one that we have at
the moment
everything else has been agreed the
pitch roof would um allow for extra
storage space to make the building more
useful to us this build is in a street
of Victorian semi-detached buildings all
of which have pitched roofs
um
planning officers say that the the
pitched tile drove that we propose in my
our building would be uh dominant and
and discordant with the street view how
can this be so the only flat roofs are
the two are on the two lock-up garages
further up on the same side of the road
I've asked local residents what they
think and every one of the 66 people who
have signed my petition have agreed that
it would look far better with a pitched
roof
the planning officers
um
claim that the um the picture roof would
detract from views of the neighboring
Christchurch
um this is not the view of um Dr Watson
who's the church's Minister who fully
supports my application for a pitched
roof
um and I have his permission to quote
him here he says I have no worries at
all it's at the rear of the church and
will not make any difference to us
um the the front of the church is more
important the neighboring houses at the
front that's on the um on the Osborne
roadside of the of the church
the houses and flats are are three
stories high on all have pitched roofs
um
I I'll have the unanimous support of the
broadstairs Town Council for the pitch
roof as well as the residents I've
mentioned and you're welcome to look at
the um their comments and and signatures
on the on the on the um on the petition
and I would ask you to support this
tonight please
thank you can I that's it
um and uh the planning applications
manager will now outline the report
thank you chair so the application site
is in red the main issues to consider
are the impacts on the character
appearance of the area
the benefits that have been put forward
by the applicant in terms of the
economic benefits of the increase in the
storage of the unit and then other
material planning considerations
including previous decisions made by the
council and inspector decisions so
this is
um
uh the site the site is actually that's
the church that's got the Red Dot on it
but this is the area of Grosvenor road
so to pick up the points that were
raised in terms of the character of the
area as you can see you have two-story
pitch roof properties all the way around
this collection of single story
buildings that stretch from the
left-hand side of the image all the way
to the application site which is the one
with the black roof here next to the
church
so to go down to street view
this is the building in question
um next to the church
this is a view from a bit further back
so you can see that the church behind it
and then this is the view the other side
um so the issue here um as you were
seeing from the report comes from the
inspector's decision on a previous
proposal now we I will show the previous
proposals
um and they are the decision was made in
relation to a full two-story building
but what the inspector decision did
identify is something particular about
this character of the area and I'm going
to read it out as it's in the report as
well as a quote despite being something
of an anomaly in the street scene the
existing office building is visually
unassuming and Street Scene the lack of
dwellings fronting the road in this area
and the small scale unobtrusive and
low-rise built formal development here
gives a relatively open character this
part of Grove and road with notable
separation between the front of Grove
and Road properties and the rear
elevations of Osborne Road whilst the
quality of the existing office building
or the garage and outbuildings are not
particularly High the arrangement gives
a spatial feel to the road which forms a
key part of his existing character
so this is the elevations of the
existing building
so you can see it's a single story with
a mono pitch roof
so the inspector was talking about this
proposal for a two-story house which was
refused and was dismissed at appeal
then subsequent application was also
refused by the council for a two-story
property on on the site again on the
basis of the first floor Edition that
was being made following the inspector's
decision on the 2016 application and
then we come to the approval on the site
so this was approved to allow for an
increase in the footprint of the site
but not to go up so looking at the floor
plan you can see there was a front
extension and a change in the design of
the front elevation to allow the stool
to be extended and that was considered
by the council to not result in any harm
to the character the area because the
main issue the inspector had raised was
about basically a first floor and this
increased scale of the building
um so
this is just the other elevation of what
was approved
um so this is
um the design of the current proposal
but it's also exactly the same design of
of the 2022 application that was refused
because of the impact on the street
scene by the council so the reason for
refusal is identical to the previous
reason for refusal that's put before
members because whilst we've considered
the additional information that's been
provided it's not considered the
economic benefits outweigh the reason
given previously to refuse the
application so
it's considered
if I move on to the block plan
specifically
um so you can see that the you have a
pitch roof and and in terms of the
argument about the there are pitch roofs
in the area as I mean the applicants
demonstrating it there on the on the
plan
um this is more about the increased
scale because what we're talking about
is the first floor within the pitch roof
um specifically uh you've got the issue
of obviously the relationship with the
church it's clearly not as significant
as if it was a full two-story property
but you can see that the actual the
ridge height is above the top of the
parapet this is set back so if you look
at this you can see that the pitch roof
bit in the middle is here the front
elevation is set back set in front here
for the church so it's set back however
obviously as you saw from the images the
whole side elevation is obviously flint
and again the inspector specifically
talked about the church and the views of
the church along the road being quite
significant in terms of actually
contributing to the character of the
area
um
we've previously refused the first four
Edition here three times uh he is
considered that the creation of a first
floor there would be out of keeping with
this stretch specifically as identified
by the inspector as I mentioned it's an
identical design of what we've already
refused
um and and officers are concerned about
the residential appearance that that's
being created and that it would
um you know it has the potential whilst
it's adjacent to a larger building it
does have a potential to erode that
spacious character and diminish it to
the extent that um you know we'd have to
look at every proposal that came forward
for other plots along there on their own
merits but obviously this is this would
go against the specific character
identified by the inspector and
therefore it is recommended for refusal
thank you chair
thank you I move that the office's
recommendation for refusal as adopted
can the vice chair please second
it
thank you um so we will now debate in
usual way I have councilor Gala first
thank you chair and thank you Mr
Livingstone for the report
um I might I call yeah I called this in
I'm not um the councilor for this Ward
um but I am the councilor for Saint
Peter's reward in which
the four candles sits and it has the
applicant said it is a thriving business
I won't I don't have to declare an
interest because I'm not a drink
I don't drink alcohol so I don't
frequent the business but I live quite
close to it and I can see that it is a
busy thriving growing business
so I called this in to broadstairs the
Peterstown Council to for discussion
and consideration because as we've heard
with with other board says and features
applications we take very seriously the
um the impact on surrounding area when
considering proposals so I thought it
was right and proper that we considered
whether this would have we thought or
they thought this should have an adverse
impact on the area and they unanimously
um decided that it they thought it
wouldn't
um
and I I agree with them I don't think it
it does
um
there are three right at the start of Mr
Livingston's presentation he mentioned
three considerations that we should we
should
um consider the first I think was around
the impact on the area
and I think we've seen although
the the the these this building the
building next to it don't have pitch
roof the area that is surrounded by
pitch roofs and Pitch roofs higher than
the picture
move here so I don't think that is
necessarily A consider a reason for
refusal
um
the do the economic benefits outweigh
the
um the the proposed the application and
I think
um as I think there are economic
benefits we need to be supporting small
businesses as has been mentioned
previously in the area and I think this
will enable the small businesses that is
quite successful to grow
and whether there are any other
considerations I I
don't believe I mean the one other
consideration that was mentioned was the
refusal of the ice similar but not the
same previous application for a taller
house than this is
um and where where obviously we do have
to consider that I don't believe that it
outweighs the benefit of allowing this
proposal so obviously I'm I'm mind I'm
looking forward to hearing from any
other members of the committee uh about
this but I think I'm I would be minded
to
um not support the officer's
recommendation and ask for this
application to be approved thank you
thank you councilor Kane
thank you this isn't a question or
anything can you go back and show me
again the two previous
applications but then
um yeah so the one after that the one
that was this so that was the second one
yeah okay and now can you go back to
what is there now
the actual photo
yeah okay thank you I just wanna
councilor Moore
yes thank you chair
um this site has been before us on
numerous occasions and each time it was
for a residential property or gave the
impression that it was going to be
residential accommodation and I think
that was the main reason why uh btsp was
refusing it in the first instance
um
I agree with Council Garner that um
you know we should be supporting local
businesses
um and I think as long as the planning
has a restriction on it that this is not
to be used for habitable accommodation
of any kind and only for storage as a
commercial Enterprise I would have
thought on this instance with the uh
extra space that they've got that would
benefit them and I would then be in
favor of supporting the applicant as
long as it was only for commercial use
and so therefore it has a condition on
it thank you chair
thank you chair
um so the property wouldn't benefit from
permitted development rights if granted
for the current use because it's been
great it would be granted after the
journal rights came in because the
government introduced saying that means
you can't game the system by doing a PD
change after the event so I mean
um the issue is that once the scale of
the property is established
um then obviously a subsequent
application to consider whether or not
that is changed into residential could
be made but we're planning permission
that we would then look at things like
um quality of accommodation size of
accommodation but it would obviously
this would establish the scale of the
building that is permitted on the screen
I'm sorry on the side
um sorry was there another hand yes so a
counselor bayford
thank you chair yeah I mean I agree with
previous speakers I I think that the
the
slight increase in bulk
um is far outweighed by the economic
benefits of the application I think it's
a great Improvement on what's been
um the applications that have been made
before on I really can't really agree
with the officers recommending
recommendation to refuse thank you
councilor wing
uh it uh Mr Livingstone could you just
confirm because it does look like a
house although it said it's a story it
looks like a house he's got a front door
on a garage and a window at the top
which would clearly could be a bedroom
uh if once this is if this was approved
further down the line could they apply
for change of use
there's nothing to preclude an
application coming in the main thing
here is is we obviously aren't
considering it being a dwelling but the
visual appearance is something that is
under consideration
um obviously as I say it must have been
I haven't because we don't need to
um there's no requirement for us to look
at the issue of how much internal floor
space there is whether it's adequate
Outlook if it's two bed property doesn't
have play Space all that stuff we
haven't we haven't looked at it we
haven't assessed it so I can't speak to
that it's more about the scale of the
first floor that's that's our concerned
yes thank you chair I've just got to
disagree with councilor bayford she said
it's uh she said it's a slight increase
in bulk
um I think it's it's more than the 50
increase in bulk
um
and that's all I want to say thank you
councilor Mata face
um I just wanted to ask um could you go
back to the pick the photograph with the
building next to the church
the other way yeah
I have at the moment
it's obvious yeah they're not defined
it's set quite a long way back from the
rear of the church isn't it so there can
be no change there and it's got parking
space which is quite a novelty there so
it's only going to be going up it's not
coming forward at all
so single story element is coming
forward of this so the basically the
pitch roof goes on top of the existing
structure which includes the first floor
within it and then you have a the
extension which has been approved as a
flat roof extension which basically
removes the the white van parking space
and that would have a smaller pitch roof
on top so that it's it's obviously this
is the view in terms of you so you can
imagine what's what's obviously changing
there
yeah I'll go back just to show the
elevations sorry
um
so here we go so so front elevation here
so the bit on the left is the and then
this is the side elevation actually
stand as if you're standing on the
church you can see the front bit there
coming out
okay any other questions or comments
in that case uh we'll now put the motion
for the officer's recommendation for
refusal to the vote those in favor of
refusing this application
and those against
me
so two in favor of seven guys
so the officer's recommendation is lost
and I'll hand back to Mr Livingstone for
the next step
um thank you chair so if members are
minded to approve the application uh
then specific grounds have to be given
as to why um it is being approved in
this instance
um obviously it has been mentioned about
the specific benefits economic benefits
of the expansion of the of the business
and that that would outweigh the impact
on the character of the area
um I would suggest if it's being
approved obviously we would look for
safeguarding conditions specifically for
example with regards to materials but to
be used and that we would have a look at
the samples of those materials
and it would be for a member to propose
a motion to approve with with those
reasons or any other reasons that they
consider outweigh the officer
recommendation
and the seconder
and in that case those in favor
oh sorry it was counselor
any any against
sorry I was a bit too quick there those
in favor
and those against
and abstentions
thank you that's uh in favor of that it
to eleven one one thank you
and uh just to say that the the loss uh
the refuse sorry the loss of the
officer's original recommendations was
two in favor seven against with four
abstentions
um I'm just going to suggest we take a
five minute Comfort break if anyone
wants to nip out stretch their legs or
whatever
um thank you and uh we'll be back in
five minutes
can we reconvene please
thank you councilor Alvin for returning
and as much appreciated
so
um if everyone's ready uh speaking uh so
this sorry this is a gender item 4G the
Royal at 51 Harper Place Ramsgate
speaking under Council rule 20.1 we have
councilor Austin you have three minutes
thank you chair
um this application I'm speaking on
behalf of myself as award counselor but
also
um trying to reflect the views of
Ramsgate Town Council on this matter and
those residents who've been in touch
recently to express their concerns about
it this application got a bit lost I
think during the perder period and local
election period so it hasn't been as
much publicized as they would have
expected it to be so therefore there are
not many objections on the portal but
there have been quite a lot of uh emails
back and forth since it was featured in
the Isle of news this week
um I would like to point out that we are
fully in favor of Thorley taverns
they're an excellent local employer
um and there's a lot of good things
about this application we're quite happy
with the fact that there are plenty of
other amenities in the area and that
losing the public house is not a problem
we are delighted to see the use of a
Brownfield site for flats and some of
the sustainability measures and so on
are excellent
we don't in principle object to the
modern design and we understand the
concerns that have been expressed about
Pastiche however this is a revised set
of plans and I believe many residents
believe and many Ramsgate Town councils
believe it is that this proposal is
still too large and obtrusive
it is not in keeping and we are very
concerned that it will have a damaging
effect on the seafront of the only Royal
Harbor in the country
uh the conservation officer starts by
saying the Royal Hotel is situated in an
incredibly prominent location central to
Ramsgate Conservation Area and opposite
the harbor I don't think it's an
incredibly prominent location but I
think what is incredible is the idea
that we can allow as large and obtrusive
a development as is proposed here
there is a reference in the
documentation which is extensive to the
various elements of the local plan which
require new development not to detract
from the immediate or wider landscape uh
the primary aim of new development is to
promote and reinforce local character
and provide high quality and inclusive
design
proposals should therefore relate to
surrounding development
the most worrying aspect from my point
of view and I'm sure this is about
technical terminology that I don't
understand but the conservation officers
report which says although the scheme's
presence is felt I would not consider
this harm to be more than substantial
I am astonished that as the custodians
of the only Royal Harbor in the country
we are considering any form of harm let
alone harm that is no more than
substantial
I believe and various of my colleagues
believe that this application should go
back to Thorley taverns with a view to
reducing the height of the building by
one floor and reconsidering some of the
aspects that the thanet Heritage and
design Forum uh looked at most
particularly they say this location is
worthy of far better treatment I can put
it no better myself
thank you I will now hand over to the
planning applications manager to outline
the report
thank you chair the application site is
here in Red so the proposal is for the
change of use of the public house and
Two Flats to a class e-commercial unit
on ground floor with
um eight Flats
um eight new Flats being proposed with
the retention of the Two Flats and that
follows a five-story side extension a
roof extension to the existing building
and a three-story building to the rear
following demolition of side elements
and building to the rear so the main
issues for consideration are the
principle of development impact on the
conservation area and the adjacent grade
2 listed building the impact on
neighbors and of course Highway impacts
as well as well as any other material
planning considerations so
site is marked in red I think most
members will know where this site is on
Harbor parade opposite the harbor as
mentioned by cancer Austin so this is a
3D just showing
um the building itself of the royal
adjacent to the Royal Sailors rest
we then have the image on street level
and then set back so this is a a long
stretch of of development which is very
prominent when you're traveling from the
south west and we will look at views as
well from the
Northeast I suppose on Madeira walk as
well
so this is just a bit of a closer view
of the royal itself at the moment
and this is the view up
um
you know up um sorry it's Harbor Street
um my brain froze there uh on Harbor
streets this is the return elevation and
we'll look at the elevations of this in
a moment
um and then you've got the listed
building and then you've got the side
extension here so as we'll see from the
plans this is the element to be
demolished with the extension
constructed within this Gap
uh even got this view as well which
again shows that side element here
and then obviously the Royal background
there
um now what we're going to do is have a
little look at the rear so this is
um again a 3D image looking down so you
can see there's a large collection of
buildings to the rear you have um this
the sort of lighter gray uh section of
building which is part of this site and
then you also have this area to the
north of that on the image where there's
a lot of plant equipment as well that's
also part of the site as well so that is
the section that's to be demolished
um and then this is a view then looking
on top of that light gray section
towards that at the moment two-story
structure with the chimney which is to
be demolished as part of this and this
is the site of the three-story structure
to be developed at the rear
and so this is a view then from the
image where if you're here and you've
got the harbor behind you and the
building obviously the raw behind you if
you go to your left and look down you
can see that there is actually behind
that uh red sort of almost like a fence
but it's the red structure on the left
hand side you can see there's actually
access to the building at the rear just
to give members an idea of of that there
is access to this building at the moment
but obviously that's proposed to be
demolished
and then this is just a view back
towards see the structure at the moment
so the existing floor plans show you've
got quite a large expanse of of building
which is a large part used for the the
Royal Pub itself so you've got basement
and the ground floor plans there all
connected with the Royal and then also
the first floor plan on the left-hand
side which is also connected with the
Royal and then you've got on the right
hand side you've got one of the
residential units which is a second
floor level and then you've got this
unit at the moment which is you know
within the
uh the the top floor of the property
so
um
in terms of the principle of development
as already mentioned the site is a is a
Brownfield site it's proposing this is
proposing uh eight new units obviously
it has members are very aware Council
cannot demonstrate a five-year supply of
housing land therefore any contribution
to the need to provide housing has to be
given significant weight in in weighing
up the determination of the application
so that is the the sort of starting
point the loss of the public house is
considered in the report under policy
cm02
um
our view as as put forward by the
applicant as well is that there are
multiple Public House in the vicinity
and therefore the loss of this Pub
wouldn't result in a a significant
reduction in in community facilities in
the area so the principle of development
and the loss to provide a a commercial
unit and it's except it was a commercial
unit because it's it's in the Town
Center area so we need that primary
Frontage still at ground floor that's
obviously what they're proposing but
there's no end user identified yet but
the principle developing for that is
acceptable
so in terms of the actual design itself
as mentioned it is a contemporary design
it proposes to use modern metal cladding
um that um you know is is aiming to
blend between the red tile hung building
on the left hand side rather than
adopting a as mentioned a Pastiche
approach with the Royal Sailors rest on
the left hand side you can see at the
top of the building
um the red dotted line which was the
previous height as submitted the roof
and that extension was higher that was
reduced obviously following officers
stating that it needed to reduce because
it was coming too high against the
listed building now obviously we've
talked a bit about contemporary design
before at committee obviously those of
you that were here prior to the election
will remember the belgrave road
application and obviously the materials
are quite a key point about how
development comes forward on a site
quite like this
to come to council Austin's point with
regards to the conservation officer's
perspective on it the wording
specifically mentioned there is is less
than substantial harm that's the
specific wording in the mppf So within
the mppf what it talks about is
obviously significant weight has to be
given to any impact on a designated
Heritage asset so Conservation Area or
indeed list of building
any impact has to be taken and put given
a note you know quite a bit of weight or
great weight I think is the exact
wording however there are levels of harm
which are delineated in the mppf
substantial harm is you're demolishing a
listed building you know it's that level
of harm is what we're talking about
and the specific reason why that wording
is used is because if there is harm to a
conservation area or a listed building
whilst there is a duty statutory Duty
for the council to try and preserve the
character of conservation over list of
building the mppf mandates that we are
required to consider public benefits
against any less than substantial harm
so that's the reason why that is the
test under the mppf
so
obviously in looking at this proposal
and the fact that it does take on a a
modern design and it does fill in the
Gap and go above
um you know the roof of the existing
property
um does create an impact on the area it
is a change this is an additional mass
and that obviously has to be considered
against those benefits I mentioned about
Brownfield development and eight Flats
in this instance
so just to go through some of the other
materials and issues on on this one
obviously you can see there are inset
balconies on the left hand side here so
these aren't balconies that protrude
it's that they are actually the as
you'll see for the floor plans they're
in set you've also got roof lights which
are set flush within the the proposed
roof slope there are some 3D
visualizations which are used for
representation only but they give you a
bit more of an idea because
um you know from the eaves height this
roof is pitching back this is not a flat
entity at the top at roof level
so looking at the side elevation again
this is a a roof that would
um you can see that the only element
that's changing here in terms of the
roof extension is that what will happen
here is the mansard roof that's
currently in place would basically
continue to extend up and if I go back
you'll be able to see
this so you can see on the right hand
side of the image you can see the
mansard roof here goes up at a very high
angle and that would just continue with
the roof extension as proposed in terms
of the metal clad roof
you also have a change in so much as
there is a dormal window that's being
added
um on the on the corner as well as a new
roof light that's that's being put in
there all the existing windows at first
floor all the all the existing windows
are being basically retained within the
Royal itself
then looking at the rear elevation of
the front building
so this is showing so where we were
looking from is on the left hand side of
the image you can see again where that
mansard goes up to the point again you
can see that dotted line about how the
roofs come down and you can see how that
roof at the rear is sort of full height
so it's not pitching away at the rear
it's just a full height five story
whereas at the front as you'll see from
the 3D that those top two stories are
pitching away from the street but you
can see there's a bit of a change in
materials here you've also got these two
bay windows specifically that are put
forward for secondary bedrooms these
have Windows on the side rather than a
window on the back so you can't look out
from those windows but you've got views
and light coming through the side and so
we'll look at that on the floor plan as
well
so then what we're going to look at as
well is the rear building so
the Gap here that you can see is a rear
Courtyard that's being proposed to be
created so this is to provide
effectively a gap between the ground
floor first floor and second floor
accommodation of the rear building with
the building at the front which is why
you have those sort of bay windows that
are designed as they are on the back of
the front building as we've just seen
there's also as you can see on the left
hand side here there is a connecting
section to provide more accommodation
for one of the flats at the rear but
just to give you the elevations of of
this building at the rear
um actually sorry there's the 3D here so
we're now looking as you can see towards
the harbor but on a 3D image so we're
looking the other ways the photos that
we saw on top of the roof from the gray
roof here looking back
so you can see you've got a very heavily
built up area at the rear here and one
of the key issues that we've been
looking at is you know increase what
happens when you increase the height of
the structure that's there by an
additional story what they are proposing
to do is to create a a partially covered
Terrace area so the image on the left is
if you are standing uh I suppose on the
properties in Harbor Street so building
at the front is on your left hand side
in that image and then you're seeing the
elevation there so there's a partially
covered roof Terrace and you may see
there's a condition on which is
requiring details of some screening to
be put up along there to avoid there
being any impact on the first floor or
Windows of the property on Harbor Street
but you can see then on the right hand
side this is the front elevation of the
rear building so this is what faces the
that back elevation of the front
building
you can again see where there's a slight
change in the bolt because of where
they've put the roof Terrace here so
it's not full the whole section is not
fully um free story but the bottom two
floors are really mimicking the scale of
the developments there at the moment but
obviously they've had to accommodate
windows for the accommodation
so to move through the floor plans you
have the basement which is serving the
commercial area so then you've got the
commercial area
um on the sort of main body of the the
Royal building as it is with the the
steps going down internally into that
basement then you have
um two entrances to get to the flats one
on Harbor Street and one on Harbor
parade you have the bin storage
um that's directly accessible from the
road
um just to be clear there's a condition
that would be proposed on here which
would mean that the bin storage doors
have to open inwards rather than
outwards as shown as planned because you
can't go over the highway but then what
you have is the Courtyard at the rear
here and then you have three units in
total in that rear building so one of
those units is on the left hand side
here and one of the issues that we were
looking at when seeking amendments is to
ensure there's enough adequate light and
outlook for the accommodation created so
this is a one bed unit it hits the
national described space standards they
have added some screening internally to
try and avoid there being a direct
privacy impact this obviously isn't a
visual issue and that's why obviously
there's a bit of a distinction between
the cases we've had earlier about the
visual impact of a landscape this is
about actually providing a sort of
almost a delineation of private space
but also an alleviation of privacy there
is an element of buyer beware here but
obviously we are conscious that we don't
want to approve substandard
accommodation we do think that with the
the combination of the window
Arrangement they've got and the
Landscaping that that flat specifically
is sufficient in terms of the living
conditions that will be created then at
the rear you've also got part of a
mazonet which if you stay with the rear
building here includes a more
accommodation on the right hand side of
this rear building you've then got some
stairs that came up from the ground
floor that provide first floor
accommodation for the other unit the
last unit at the rear and then I'm going
to go up to the next plan to just talk
about that rear unit and then you have
the rest of the accommodation for the
rear unit and if we go back to the front
building if we're back to the first
sorry if I go back to the first floor
so this is where I get to be more
straightforward you've got two units on
each floor this is effectively where you
are you know they're replacing the units
that were there there were two units on
the upper floors but then you've got two
units on the first floor primary Outlook
to the front over the harbor
then you've got second floor plan again
similar Arrangement two units primary
Outlook over the harbor
similar range on the third floor two
units primary Outlook over the harbor
and then there's the roof accommodation
so what you can see here is that the
roof accommodation doesn't extend to the
very front of the building because you
can see on this floor plan here you've
actually got the roof part which is
where it's sloping back but this is all
one unit on the the top of the property
so again all of these units Accord with
the nationally described space standards
they are all spacious and they are
considered to have suitable light and
Outlook provided
so in terms of perspective views so
these are given as representations
um and obviously what would be approved
are the elevations just be absolutely
clear These are 3D renders they're not
going to be you know they're not
scalable but we do think they they give
an impression of the extent of the
building the extent of the development
and as mentioned the key issue is the
impact on the conservation area and the
adjacent listed building so to give
members some context and I'm sure
Ramsgate members will will know this
obviously the the Royal building itself
is is obviously not a I suppose a
historic building as the Royal Sailors
rest is they're also as previously
extended over the site of the Royal
the Royal is therefore a relatively new
building in the conservation area
obviously what is they're not proposing
to demolish that building and that was
obviously a very specific sort of start
to the design that they look to do and
obviously then the issue is how do you
develop around that building if you are
going to provide more accommodation
there and obviously which has then
informed the design that they've come up
with for something more contemporary now
I do think it's important to state that
obviously the grain of the elevation is
simply not shown in this perspective
because obviously you've seen from the
elevations the fact that these are
panels of metal cladding so they are
broken up rather than being shown as one
homogeneous color on this but the main
thing here to look at in terms of the
issue that's identified within the
conservation officers comment is about
the scale of the roof extension and
specifically the fact obviously the
height has been reduced we'll see what
we're looking at is is it significantly
harmful to the in terms of the impact on
the listed building so the fact that
there is a side elevation that's exposed
of the list of building at the moment as
if we go back here
is an important factor however obviously
historically as I mentioned that is
simply not what the Royal sales rest
looked like so we do consider that you
could develop something in that Gap and
the principle of that sort of
development would sit comfortably within
the conservation era it's just about
whether or not the design and scale of
this building is acceptable as a
contemporary addition rather than trying
to adapt to the design of the buildings
either side but but paying regards to
the material palette so one of the other
issues that we raised a concern about
related to the view from Madeira walk
because whilst it's not maybe as
prominent as the views around the harbor
it is still when you're in both Albion
Gardens but also going down Madeira walk
you really can see that side elevation
of the royal and you can see the top of
the chimneys of the listed building so
this was an issue in terms of what was
obscured do you obscure the actual
chimneys of the list of building by
doing this from looking at the
elevations and considering those scale
drawings the view of those chimneys
specifically is still to be retained so
again that that sort of uh I suppose
dominance of that height is still
sustained as part of the character of
the area in our view by doing the
proposal so
this is a situation where it is an
unbalanced approval recommendation sorry
defer and Delegate for approval subject
to the Sam's contribution being secured
through a legal agreement
we do think that there is an appropriate
balance struck here between the design
the conservation area and the list of
building and the provision of eight
units in a highly sustainable Brownfield
site and therefore the recommendation is
to defer and Delegate for approval
subject conditions and as I say a legal
agreement for that sounds contribution
thank you chair
thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation for deferral and delegate
is approved with the vice chair please
second
indeed
thank you and do I have any speakers
councilor Auburn
yeah thank you chair
um
this is a this is a push push you pull
your kind of thing you know
um and uh
I think the contrast I'm not
particularly against the contrast of the
uh of the materials against the listed
building
um
it was just the bulk at the top of the
building of the top of the of the
extension
um
which is my humble opinion is too high
I just thought it needed to come down to
the level of the current roof of the
royal
um and that's what concerns me
um
the buildings at the back everything
like not a problem I'll go along with
what councilor rossin has said as well
um and um so
foreign
the development itself and I've got no
problem with having a development there
and having that extension I just believe
that it's
just that bit too high and
you know
and as it's been said
conservation of area right adjacent to a
listed structure you know and we do have
we do make a lot of uh noise about
effects enlisted listed buildings when
dealing with planning applications
um
so I'm having difficulty with this
um because of the height and that's
purely the only thing that I really have
a difficulty with thank you
Russell makinson
I don't have any difficulties with it I
find the Royal building
very lumpish not terribly attractive
um not enhanced by the existing
someoneage on it
I think it's very important that we use
these little infill sites Brownfield
sites
to provide more housing and then
I'm not worried about the height I don't
think you'll be aware of it
from the street the the building to the
other side to the east is is much more
attractive than the um Royal building
which others the planning Officer says
is quite a recent building
um and I think it's quite right that
they use entirely different materials as
they do in places like Italy
where they're building up against
quite a lot of um
old classical buildings
to not not Pastiche them
so I would support this
thank you
Council a wing
I mean I agree there's a continuous
Frontage there apart from that Gap so
your natural instinct is to put
something in there when you've got the
opportunity to do so
but I think the gaps too and I'm very
much a supporter of of modern designs
coming into conservation areas because I
think it's about creating new Heritage
for the future and not just trying to
recreate what we've already got there
and I agree that that the Royal building
it's not a particularly great looking
building at presently but I just think
the Gap is too small and I I just find
that that modern infill hideous I have
to say whether it's the the scale of the
height of on it whether it's the fact
that there isn't any symmetry or or or
linking it's meant to be part of the
building but I don't see how there's no
signature apart from the color of the
building to link it there it's going to
stick out like a sore thumb on that
seafront I have to say and I'm I'm
really confused about the consistency
with which we approve or disapprove
things because we've just taken umbrage
over a a an extractor fan on top of a
building in broadstairs well this is the
dam site bigger than an extractor fan
and I think we should be sending it back
and we maybe should be looking at some
of the advice that uh the REM the
Heritage Forum having having Ramsgate I
I you know I'm all in favor of the
infill I think it's a great idea I think
it's a positive move because that area
is looking a bit down at the moment the
other concern I've got is that if we do
approve there's already two significant
Builds on Harbor Street going on and the
chaos it's creating with delivery of
materials removal of materials
scaffolders being present is quite
difficult so I'd like to think that
there would be some sort of a management
of the building of the actual process of
building this building in such a prime
location because it is going to create
quite a lot of disturbance
thank you chair just to come back on a
couple of those points um yeah it's
proposed for a construction management
plan condition
um it's also there's also another
condition which would require measures
to protect the list of building during
construction as well it's obviously
incredibly important for this I think
just to come back on
I think obviously the the two
applications that you mentioned it's not
a comparison obviously there it
naturally it all scales I think is the
main thing I would say and it's
obviously every case on its own merits
um but I appreciate the point you're
making
counciloruzeki
oh thank you chair yeah looking at this
um I don't I don't have great
difficulties with it I think the Royal
wasn't a fantastic building at the
beginning
um and as you said it it is actually
more a lot more modern
um than the uh building to the left of
it
um but if we go even further over to the
left of that building we find a Travel
Lodge on a very modern building uh
Etc so I I I I can't see there's a big
issue with that I think that uh
um
you know frontages will change things
will modernize slightly
um
no I'll be probably supporting this
thank you
anyone else
so I would like to make my own comments
as one of the counselors as an East
Cliff counselor
um very much close to our Ward I broadly
like it but I do think that the changes
that have been made to the outside of
the royal have taken away from it
fitting in with the Heritage area and
it's making it look rather Bland
compared to what is round to the right
from here
I'm happy with the height but I would
like the infill to be maybe a little bit
lower although I'm quite happy with that
so my inclination is I think someone
else said it just now is
um to send it back in other words to to
send it back and come back to us
um with perhaps some of the the concerns
that we've raised to be addressed that's
my view thank you does anyone else have
anything else to add after that
and which in which case
um we will now put the motion for the
officer's recommendation which was to re
defer and delegate to the vote those in
favor of defer and delegate
and against
[Music]
so that's
um
carrot thank you
sorry the numbers again are nine in
favor four against
and it's got to be an extension here so
it's 13.
14.
yeah so I'm one abstention thank you
um that concludes the public speaking
for this meeting I will now call upon
the clock to read out the remaining
planning applications if a member wishes
to reserve an application will they
please call out as the clerk reads thank
you thank you chair
so we have ao2 Winter Gardens Fort
Crescent Margate
803 which is also Winter Gardens Fort
ao4 Ramsgate Bowling Club Bowling Greens
Royal Esplanade Ramsgate
and r07 kiosk at Royal Victoria Pavilion
Harbor parade Ramsgate
thank you can I have a proposal to move
that the applications that have not been
reserved be determined in accordance
with the officer recommendations
councilor Auburn and secondary councilor
bayford
do members agree
and thank you so for the benefit of the
public I will call upon the clock to
read out the applications that have been
determined
thank you chair so again that's ao2
Winter Gardens Ford Crescent Margate 803
Winter Gardens Fork Crescent Margate
804 groundskate boarding Club Bowling
Greens Royal Esplanade Ramsgate and r07
kiosk at Royal Victoria Pavilion Harbor
parade Ramsgate thank you
this meeting thank you for your
attendance and good night